yeah welcome to this video I'm playing
God want again going muscle stem off
done trying the English Defence this
tricky b6 opening day is playing c4
let's see I expect a 3m yeah miss some
classical positional player and they
very often go from the a3 line yeah
let's see d 5 but d5 and Knight f3 does
not work so well together this only 94
is interesting in term leads to a very
Queens Indian type of position where
white has played to the move a 3 and
it's not so clear that this move is
helping him so much okay um c5 is
actually what I'd like to play i'm not
sure if i should play it here or after
castling
now let's let's castle first I can I can
always play this move I hope okay so c5
was my intention yo okay let's use the C
pawn to fight for the center maybe
there's a difference if we do go and see
one okay the difference to to the
earlier c5 but how to continue here okay
i can dig here and that's tricky just
just d6 hmm
yeah I guess so it weakens the e6 square
considerably but I guess I I need to
play 97 so now later I'm not sure how I
should continue him so he's preparing
the capture I guess on e4 by covering
the d5 pawn now i can simply take on c3
okay let's let's do that then play 97
completing development it looks and it
looks fairly solid for black yeah maybe
trying to play you form but I have f4 as
a reply so i can maybe night c4 i have
this cat also be on my agenda yes still
he wants to play a form
therefore right I guess so I don't
really see but I can play a FOIA on your
phone if not I'm in trouble okay h3
probably protecting the g four square
for 495 the scandal firms became i
wonder if i should take myself and play
a form what why not actually and then a
form especially after h3 the sem gains
in strength because g3 is weakened okay
just put it on five Bishop c8 next
yes you can try to play a forum and this
is obviously very critical the question
is if I can make a sacrifice out of this
and can and should we should see a test
the move I'm talking about takes bishop
83 they can take he can take these six
it is a dangerous attack down
not sure okay maybe I'll regard regret
this later but it's a it's difficult
difficult to to assess I thought I have
push-ups e8 coming and then it's in it's
interesting play for black anyway
and can not the same
I think I'm thinking about rook air-five
look at five and end and over this kind
of IDM this first if you take V please
no GI i think i can take it and if we
for i can take a form so we cannot
protect it from the side
maybe a move like Roxy 3 so after after
look Emma h5 he's got a phone exactly
this is he is playing
okay this is a very drastic measure but
let's let's see what happens takes rook
takes Queen takes root g two wins the
Queen this was saw that diem
time warning threaten work takes h3
yeah very good for me but i have spent
far too much time
Queen f2 even coming check yeah this
check is the same I mean it's still
completely lost for white but time was
it was just spending far too much time
far too much time black for fits on time
yeah he's actually don't what five
seconds now as well yeah a bit of a
shame where I mean I always spend too
much time I know but yeah probably
around here it was clear that black is
it's very good yeah I think and I should
have played justjust much quicken those
Musa could have been played quick I'm
and I probably even missed some in some
clearer some clear removes yeah fact
this is this is still good okay Mia I'm
missing a key movie and this of course I
saw but I didn't see and what is so
especially great about this and the key
point is I can I can play this
intermediate move on the tech f4 he has
a hard time to prevent me getting this
porn or entering one before I have
computer files this of course instantly
yeah
maybe I had something better around here
input yeah yeah I thought about Bishop
c8 but this is probably not working
right I thought Knight f3 or Ruby too
yeah this is sufficient I should do that
this was good black is simply better
because the White King is weak but I
spent far too much time in the process
alright thanks for watching